LARRY YANG: Let's start with a
recap of some of the benefits
that Play Billing brings.
We help you in four areas.
First, we give you access
to users around the world.
Second, we give
you choice, choices
in how to monetize in your app.
Third, we give you tools in
how to optimize your purchase
experience.
And lastly, we make
it all effortless,
so you can focus on building
a great user experience.
Let me walk you through
a few highlights
in each of these areas.
First, let's talk about how
Play Billing gives you access
to buyers around the world.
Google Play reaches billions
of users around the world
in over 190 countries.
That makes Google Play
one of the world's largest
mobile payments platforms.
Since we've met last year, we've
grown in a number of areas.
We've added seller
support in 31 new markets.
Now, developers in 112 countries
can now sell on Google Play.
We continue to add
new payment methods.
We've extended our
eWallet support
to over a dozen countries now.
And in India, we're
in the process
of rolling out Unified
Payments Interface, one
of the most popular digital
payments platforms in India.
And lastly, we continue to
invest in our carrier billing
relationships.
We now have partnerships
with over 170 carriers,
reaching over a billion
active mobile devices.
That means you can now sell
to over a billion users
on mobile devices
with mobile accounts.
They don't need a credit card.
They don't need a bank account.
They just need their phone.
Now let's talk about how we give
you choices in how to monetize.
For a long time
now, we've given you
support in selling
in-app purchases, where
you can sell one-time items,
such as gems or swords.
We offer subscriptions so you
can grant continued access
to your content or service.
And you can sell
paid apps, where
you collect a one-time payment
upfront before your user can
download and install your app.
A couple of months ago, we
launched rewarded products.
Over 1,000 of you
have already started
using rewarded products.
With rewarded products, you
can now sell items to a user
by having them complete
a monetizable action--
for example, watching a video.
Rewarded products is powered
by our AdMob technology,
but because it's now
built into Play Billing,
there is no extra SDK
you have to integrate.
Rewarded products is
currently in open beta.
Next, let's talk
about how we help you
optimize your
purchase experience.
The Play Console gives
you tools and reports
that help you convert your users
into buyers and your buyers
into repeat buyers.
If you're a
subscriptions developer,
we give you tools to
help you understand
who's staying on your service,
and for those who are leaving,
why they might be leaving.
Angela will share more about
these subscription tools later.
And finally, we
make it effortless
for you to earn
money with your app.
Instead of you having to build
a payment flow from scratch,
we do it for you.
And because users now see a
consistent payment experience
throughout all of Play and
all of their Play apps,
they learn to trust our service.
And research has
shown that the more
users trust a service, the
more likely they are to pay.
We store the user's
payment information,
so they don't have to enter
their payment credentials over,
and over, and over again.
And because we store
the information,
you don't have to,
because after all, you
don't want to have to
worry about securing
such sensitive
information, do you?
We take care of all the
important details in over 100
markets around the world.
For example, did you know
that in the past 18 months,
there have been a number of
tax and regulatory changes
in over 30 different
taxing authorities?
You probably didn't know
that because we took
care of those details for you.
And that frees you up to
doing what you do best--
building a great
user experience.
So you probably already know
about all these awesome things
Play Billing does for you.
So you're not here to listen
to us rest on our laurels.
So let's get to the good stuff.
What's new with Play Billing?
First off, Stephen
will come up and share
a number of exciting updates
with the Play Billing
Library, the simplest way to
integrate with our billing
platform.
After that, Angela
will come up and share
a number of new features on
our subscriptions platform.
Subscriptions is the fastest
growing monetization model
on Google Play.
Stephen.
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHEN FULWIDER: Thanks, Larry.
Let's talk about what's new
with the Play Billing Library.
To get started,
let's quickly recap
what the Billing Library is.
It's an abstraction on the
Android Interface Definition,
or AIDL, which was
the previous way
to integrate with Play Billing.
It helps to enforce
best practices
and ensure you're implementing
the API correctly.
This provides the
best experience
for you and your users.
And it greatly simplifies
staying on the latest version.
Instead of copying a
bunch of reference code,
you simply change your build
target to the latest version,
and you're good to go.
Since our initial launch we've
gotten lots of great feedback
on the Play Billing Library.
Developers who have
adopted it into their apps
have called it a
dream come true.
And we've already seen
many of you successfully
using it in production.
We recently crossed $2
billion in transactions
from apps using the
Play Billing Library.
In short, it's the best way
to integrate with Play Billing
into your application.
We want to continue to
build on this success.
That's why I'm so excited today
to announce the Play Billing
Library 2.0.
It's chock full of new features
to help you grow your business.
First, we'll help you
to access more users
across more surfaces.
We'll provide a choice
of new business models
to help you maximize your
existing revenue streams
and to explore new ones.
We're providing new APIs
to help you understand more
about your purchases,
as well as adding tools
to help you monitor
in real time.
And finally, we'll
cover how we're
making all of this available
now and in the future
to make things easy
and predictable.
First, let's dive into how we're
helping you expand your access.
Earlier, Larry
mentioned that we've
expanded to over 170
carrier partners worldwide.
But that's not the only
payment method we're expanding.
Today, we're launching support
for an entirely new class
of payments that we're
calling pending transactions.
Unlike traditional
forms of payment,
like credit cards, which can
be authorized immediately,
delayed payment methods
require the user
to take some additional
step in order
to complete the transaction.
So let's take a look
at this in action.
In this purchase
flow, you can see
the user's chosen to
complete this transaction
at their local SAL
convenience store.
Instead of the normal
Tap to Buy button,
the user is given a
payment code, which they
can use to finish the purchase.
They simply take the code to
the nearby convenience store
in order to finish the payment.
And once they pay, the
transaction we mark complete,
and their fabulous [? yak ?]
adventure will be underway.
So now you see how a delayed
transaction would work.
Examples of delayed transactions
include cash and bank transfer,
such as direct debit
and net banking.
Cash is available today to
top up in Japan and Mexico.
And we're expanding to
in-app purchasing soon.
By implementing
Billing Library 2.0,
you get access to these and
all other delayed payment
methods absolutely free.
It just works.
We're also expanding
the surfaces
where you can engage
with your users
to purchase your
content with support
for out-of-app
subscription sign-ups.
We work together with you to
surface your subscriptions
directly on your
store listing page
and allow users to subscribe
and install your app
in a single, seamless flow.
And we're not just thinking
about subscriptions here.
We'll also be bringing
this out-of-app experience
to in-app purchases.
Imagine, for example, being
able to sell a special game pack
directly on your live ops page.
We want to offer your
content to your users
where it's most
convenient for them.
This includes Android TV, Google
Assistant, Search, and Google
Home, just to name a few.
Angela will be going into
more details on this feature
in a little bit.
Now, as we expand
to more services
with out-of-app
purchases, we want
to make sure both
you and your users
continue to have a
smooth transaction
experience, between
finishing a purchase
and getting their content.
To help facilitate this,
we've added functionality
to allow you to acknowledge all
purchases with the Google Play
Billing Library or through
the Google Play Developer API.
This gives Google a signal
that you successfully
granted a purchase made in-app
or out-of-app to your user.
If the user claims they
never received a purchase,
we now have a definitive
signal to verify this.
We can also automatically
fix any purchase
which was made,
but never received,
in order to reduce the number
of users who have a bad purchase
experience.
Out-of-app purchases and
purchase acknowledgment
work hand-in-hand
to give you access
to a wide array of
new purchase services,
simultaneously ensuring
your users always
have a good purchase experience,
no matter what they buy
or where they bought it.
Next, let's talk about some of
the new choices of monetization
that are available in
the Billing Library.
We know that
promotional limited time
pricing can be big drivers
of purchase conversion.
Until now, we
haven't offered you
the ability to tell us
about those promotions.
Now we're extending
the API to support
returning both original and
promotional prices to your app.
And when we can, we can
show the promotion directly
in the Play buy flow.
This means users will get
a consistent experience
or consistent offer between
your app and our cart.
We've also added support
for custom SKU icon,
and we plan to continue
expanding this feature
to support even more
consistency between your app
and our buy flow.
We're currently testing
this feature and plan
to make this more
widely available soon.
So next, let's talk about
some of the intelligent new
features we've added to
Billing Library 2.0 to help
you optimize your integration.
First, we've made optimizations
to render the purchase screen
more quickly.
As we all know, latency
is the conversion killer.
And in Search, for
instance, we found
an additional 500
milliseconds of latency
can cause as much as a
20% reduction in traffic
and revenue.
Last year, we launched
a feature to cache
and instantly serve
the cart, as you
see on the right
side of the screen.
However today, we're only
able to offer this experience
about half the time.
With Billing Library
2.0, we've refactored
the API to ensure that you
get the zero latency purchase
at no additional cost to you.
It will result in a better
experience for your users
and increased purchase
conversion for you.
Next, we've revamped
the developer
payload to allow you
to attach your own data
to any purchase made in-app.
This can be used in many ways.
For instance, you
can attach data
about experiments that are
running for an A/B test,
or you can attach information
about an encrypted user
identifier to associate
a purchase to a user.
However you choose to
utilize the feature,
it's now available in
Billing Library 2.0.
And it can be attached while
consuming or acknowledging
any purchase.
Now, by show of
hands, how many of you
have ever shipped a
bug to production?
OK, so about half of
you raised your hands.
And the other half of you
are probably in denial.
We all know that bugs happen.
The best way to handle them is
to make sure that when they do,
you can quickly
diagnose and recover.
To that end, we've
greatly improved
the error code and
debug messages that
are available in the library.
Instead of returning
a generic error code,
we now expanded the API to
return specific, granular error
messages for each
class of exception.
This change will help you
minimize your debug time
and get things back up
and running quickly.
So now that we've covered a
lot of the great new updates
available in
Billing Library 2.0,
let's talk about how
we're changing the release
process to make it effortless
to stay up to date.
We've heard from you that
our current release process
has some areas for improvement.
First, releases are
ad-hoc and unpredictable.
This leads to
confusion on when you
need to be updated to
the latest version.
Further, there are two ways to
integrate with Play Billing.
We haven't previously defined
an official best practice.
So it's hard to know
which one you need to use.
We know we can do better here.
That's why starting today,
we're excited to announce
a predictable, yearly
release cadence.
Every I/O, starting
with this one,
will be releasing a new
major version of the library.
Each release will contain the
latest features and API changes
to ensure you have
access to everything you
need to keep your monetization
strategy at the cutting edge.
We're also announcing that
the Billing Library is now
the official way to
integrate with Play Billing.
Going forward,
these releases are
intended to be effortless
to adopt into your app
by simply updating
to the latest version
with your build
target each year.
So you'll know when
updates are coming,
so you can plan your roadmap
around this predictable
release.
Of course, no talk would
be complete without a note
from the lawyers.
So as a reminder, any
of our roadmap features
are just that--
a roadmap.
They should not be construed as
a guarantee of future releases.
I think I've done my diligence.
But we know that
simply releasing
a new version of the
library every year
isn't the whole story.
Current versions of the API
have an unpredictable support
window, which means you don't
know when you need to update
to the latest version.
We think predictability
is really important,
and that's why
starting today, we're
announcing the deprecation
of previous integrations
with Play Billing, AIDL,
and Billing Library 1.x.
But further, we're announcing
this predictable and consistent
deprecation and
sunsetting schedule.
Each year, the API version
will advance by 1--
as we mentioned, a new
major release of each I/O.
Within one year following
each major release, new apps
and app updates
will need to target
the latest version of the
Billing Library or higher.
So each release will
continue to be supported
for an additional year to
give you time to integrate
to the newest version.
And again, going
forward, this process
is meant to be very lightweight.
Simply change the build target
to point to the latest version,
and you're good to go.
So here, you can see
the two-year lifecycle
of each major version
of the Billing Library.
And because we are announcing
a new release cadence,
we want to make sure
you have plenty of time
to migrate your
existing integration.
Whether you're currently using
AIDL or Billing Library 1.x,
we're giving the full
two years for you
to migrate your integration.
Next year, you can see the
plan to release Billing Library
3.0, which will be supported
as well for two years.
And two years from now, you
can see that Billing Library
2.0 will reach its end of life.
And all new apps and app updates
should be using Billing Library
3.0 by that time.
This release and support cadence
will continue each year going
forward, with each I/O featuring
a new major release being
available and releases from
two years prior no longer being
supported for new
apps or app updates.
And again, the
lawyers do need for me
to remind you that
this is just a roadmap.
So as you can see, we've added
a lot of great new features
to Billing Library 2.0.
There's new ways to pay, new
purchases to surface from,
new models to monetize.
And this is all
brought to your users
faster with improved
debuggability
and experimentation.
And the predictable
release and support window
allows you to plan your roadmap
to keep your app up to date.
A Java version of the library
is available right now
at g.co/play/billinglibrary.
And C++ and Kotlin
are coming soon.
If you're interested,
send us an email at these
so we can get you on the list.
Now let me hand it
off to Angela to cover
what's new with subscriptions.
[APPLAUSE]
ANGELA YING: Thanks, Stephen.
So you just learned how the
Billing Library gives you
access to more users, different
choices with your monetization
models with an
optimized offering,
and all in an effortless way.
And now I want to
deep dive into one
of the fastest growing
monetization models we have--
subscriptions.
So just a show of
hands, who here
currently offer subscriptions
in their app or are planning to?
Wow.
That's, like, a lot of you.
That's like 3/4 of you.
So we've been talking
about subscriptions
here at Google I/O
for a few years now.
And that's because users
continue to love subscriptions.
They love it as a way
to try out new services,
while having the flexibility
to cancel whenever they want.
And because users
love subscriptions,
our business also
continues to grow.
Between 2016 and
2018, developers
like you have earned
four times more revenue
from subscriptions.
Now, you might think
this might just
be from all the big
developers getting bigger.
I mean, we can't all make
a Game of Thrones, right?
But guess what?
The number of apps with at
least 10,000 subscribers
also grew four times in
the same time period.
And so what that's
telling us is it's
not the big developers
getting bigger.
It's our entire
ecosystem getting bigger,
with more developers like
you successfully offering
and selling subscriptions.
So how can Google help
you grow even more?
Today, I'm going to cover
the new capabilities we built
in the subscriptions platform to
help you reach new subscribers,
as well as retain them.
So let's start with reach first.
Today, all subscriptions
are sold in-app.
And you might think,
well, obviously,
subscriptions are sold in-app.
But consider this probably
very familiar situation.
A user installs your app.
They get to a paywall.
They're like, I don't
know what this is.
So then they uninstall your
app and post a one star review
on your store listings page.
And they've never
even tried your app.
Or consider this other
familiar situation.
A user is using your app for
years using the free content,
and they never even realize that
you had a subscription with all
this amazing content behind it.
And so what if we could help
you surface your subscription
earlier, and maybe help the
user subscribe earlier, too?
So I'm super excited to announce
today Subscribe and Install.
This is a new feature to
help the user discover
that your app has
a subscription,
subscribe directly
from the Play Store,
and then we will auto install
your app in the background.
How does this work exactly?
Well, you tell us which SKU
you would like to feature on
your store listings page.
We'll offer the SKU
and change the button
where the user installs.
If it's a free trial, we'll
say Free Trial and Install.
And when the user
clicks the button,
they'll be asked to
buy the subscription.
And when that's
successful, then we
will auto install the
app in the background.
Now, as Stephen
mentioned earlier,
this does require the
new Billing Library.
We've been running an EAP
for Subscribe and Install
for the last few months with
over a dozen developers,
and we've seen some
amazing results.
We've seen an average of 34%
increase in paid subscribers.
And keep in mind
that this is actually
after their free trial.
In fact, photo editor app Pixart
tried Subscribe and Install,
and they saw an increase in
both free trials, as well as
free trial conversions.
So speaking of free
trials, free trials,
again, are a super common way
for you to acquire new users.
Over 70% of new
subscriptions are actually
coming from a free trial.
But today, free trials are
kind of one size fits all.
When you set up your
subscription SKU,
either everybody on that SKU
gets a free trial, or nobody
gets a free trial.
But so what if you want
to be more targeted?
For example, what if you want
to offer a free trial only
to users who churned
six months ago?
So I'm super excited to
announce promotion codes
for subscriptions.
In the Google Play
Console, you'll
be able to generate
one-time promotion codes.
It's super simple.
You tell us how many
promotion codes you want,
and we'll give you a
bunch of one-time codes
and a CSV for you to distribute
to your users via email,
via in-app purchase
or other channels
that you can reach the user.
And so how it works is if
the SKU doesn't have a trial,
users with a promotion
code will get a trial.
If the SKU already has a
trial, then those users
will actually get an
extended free trial.
So this is great for targeting
specific sets of users.
Imagine if you can
send a promotion code
to a user who just
abandoned your buy flow,
or to a user who churned
after never having
engaged in your most
primary feature in your app.
So that was the new acquisition
tools within subscriptions.
But once you acquire
subscribers, of course,
you need to retain them.
And so let's dive into the
new features within retention.
Today, when a user
says I'm going
to manage my subscription,
what they really mean is
they're going to cancel
your subscription.
And frankly, there's
not much else they
can do once they get to
the subscription center.
And as a result, some users
tell us when they're canceling,
I'm just canceling
because I needed a break.
Or I'm canceling
because I can't afford
the subscription this month,
but I'll be back next month.
Guess what?
Some of those users
don't come back.
Some of those users forget.
And so I'm happy to announce
that now you can let your users
pause their
subscription instead.
When you enable Pause on
the Google Play Console,
it will surface a
prompt in the cancel
flow asking the user if
they would rather pause,
instead of canceling
their subscription.
Users can also pause directly
from the subscription center
for up to three months on
a monthly subscription.
This is a great way to
save on potential churners,
especially for users who
are leaving temporarily.
So let's dive into a
specific case study.
Brazilian medical app PebMed
integrated with Pause,
and they saw an
immediate voluntary churn
reduction of 24% with very
little integration work.
This is a great
result. Now because I
have to deliver a
message from our lawyers,
your mileage may vary.
This is just a case study.
So how do you know if Pause
is going to work for you?
Well, last year, we
announced a cancel survey
that we would show when
the user's canceling
their subscription.
But this was only
available via the API.
And so that made it
difficult for many of you
to be able to
aggregate those results
and make sense of
the information.
So now we've built new reporting
in the Google Play Console.
You can access these reports
in the cancellation reporting
section.
You'll be able to see both
the aggregated fixed responses
and to look at trends over
time, as well as download
a CSV of the free form
responses users put
in when they answered other.
Both of these together should
give you actionable insights
for why users are leaving and
how you can improve your app
to keep them.
In fact, language
exchange app Tandem
used the cancellation survey
to identify and implement
new pricing optimizations.
Brain training app
NeuroNation found out that
through the cancel survey,
that one third of their users
were churning due to
cost related reasons.
And as a result,
they're now thinking
about new win-back strategies
using real time developer
notifications.
So I encourage you all,
please open your console
and check out the new
cancellation reports.
What you see might surprise you.
Ultimately, it's
going to give you
a better understanding
of who your users are
and why they're leaving.
So we've talked a lot
about voluntary churn.
Let's talk involuntary now.
So involuntary
churn is when a user
churns due to payment issues.
For example, your
credit card got stolen,
or your carrier billing
has a low balance.
This is a super
common reason why
users churn from subscriptions,
and it absolutely
can be addressed, sometimes
with even dramatic impact.
So we currently offer a feature
called Grace Period, which you
can set to three or seven days.
And right after a
payment decline,
you will give access
to the subscription
to the user for three or seven
days while in the background,
Google's retrying the
user's payment method.
But why is Grace Period
only three or seven days?
For a lot of you,
it might actually
be worth it to give
the user a little bit
more time in your
app in exchange
for extending that retry window
we have to recover the payment.
And so we've released
two new options
for Grace Period,
14 and 30 days.
Both of these will give
you a longer retry window,
so that you can reduce
your involuntary churn.
And the best thing
about this is there's
no integration required.
It's just checking a box.
So let's recap what's
going on in subscriptions.
We've announced
five new features
to help you both
reach new subscribers,
as well as retain your
existing subscribers.
The features in bold
are available today,
while the others
are coming soon.
Now let's hand it back to Larry.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY YANG: Thanks, Angela.
Phew.
OK, that was a lot
of stuff to remember.
So let me go through a
quick recap of what you just
heard today.
We're giving you additional
access to reach new buyers
by adding a new capability
of supporting delayed payment
methods, where the user
can now leave your app
and go complete the transaction
possibly with cash or bank
transfers.
We're letting you start selling
items outside of your app.
So for example, via
Subscribe and Install,
where they can sign up
for your subscription
directly from the
store listing's page.
We're improving the choices that
you have in how to monetize.
We'll now consistently
reflect your promotional offer
in our purchase flow.
For subscriptions
developers, we're
adding a new acquisition tool
by extending promotion codes
to subscriptions.
And we're helping subscriber
retention with new tools,
such as Subscription Pause
and longer Grace Periods.
We're giving you new tools to
help you optimize your purchase
conversion.
We're bringing developer payload
to the Billing Library now,
so you can add metadata
to your purchases
to do further analysis
and experimentation.
And once you've integrated
with the Billing Library,
you should start seeing faster
or improved purchase conversion
because the purchase flow
now completes more quickly.
We're going to help you launch
faster with improved error
codes, and now
subscription developers
can understand better
why your users might
be leaving with the new
cancel survey reports.
And lastly, we're making
it effortless to keep up
with all of our changes.
By integrating with the
Play Billing Library,
you now will have confidence
that you're always
getting the latest and greatest
version of our billing API.
To learn more
about Play Billing,
come visit our team, located
over in the Android Sandbox
and also over in
the Gaming Garage.
And drop by our office hours
if you have specific questions
tomorrow at 9:30.
You can also visit this
URL to get more information
about everything we
just talked about.
And Stephen, Angela, and I will
be outside right afterwards
right outside the front doors
if you want to chat with us.
And that's it.
Thanks for coming
to our session.
Please enjoy the rest of I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]